do you think a lot of people that come
here realize how maybe sometimes how
empty some of that is even if you get
the claim of many people and you have
the possessions do you think a lot of
them realize that it a lot of times it's
in the beauty of doing the work and it's
not in what they say out there I think
everybody has their own personal journey
and I do believe that you know from
working with all the celebrities that
I've worked with I've found that
sometimes the people that are the most
famous are the most lonely and I think
we all go through a personal journey
about you know trying to understand
what's really important to us and what
we want for our lives and for some
people that might be fame and fortune
and that's fine but I don't think that
that is what fulfills the soul I think
that the art and the love and the
compassion and the empathy I think those
are the things that fill that artistic
craving more than you know accolades and
money and and fame
what I'm wondering why that would be
though someone that has so many people
that wants access to them and just want
to be in the same room with them and
then be totally alone has
I think what happens is that you have so
many people when you're a public figure
that think that they know you especially
if you're really open in the press and
open about your life so these people
that want to meet you think that they're
that you're their friend or and the
truth is is that you know you're working
first of all you're working so much so
if you're you know you're working 13 to
15 hours a day you don't really have
that much time for a life outside of
your work and then you have all these
people that want a piece of you or think
that they know you and that can kind of
drive you into isolation even more
because you're not understanding
sometimes why do they feel like they
know me or why do they want to to be so
close to me and so it kind of it's scary
sometimes but then other times you know
it's such a beautiful thing to have
people feel like they know you and like
want to be around you it's kind of a
double-edged sword in a way you know I
appreciate both sides of it because I
have such supportive fans I love them
but at the same time it's like you know
when I was at my darkest moment when I
was about to make face to face no one
was there with me I was completely alone
so you know it's two sides of the coin
really
I remember seeing Lionel Richie in
public one time
I just went up to him and just said love
your work and then I kept to the back
and moved on is there a right way to
approach someone that's in the public
eye or do you kind of gauge it and see
is it appropriate for me to even go up
to the server I think I think going up
to public figures I think there's a
couple things number one like what
setting they're in I think when people
are having dinner they're having a
personal conversation like just going up
and like interrupting them and being
like oh my god I love you can I have
your autograph
I think that you have to be respectful
and sometimes there's just that right
moment where you see someone that you
really respect their body of work and it
just seems like the right time I think
you should always be yourself you know
it's if you're gonna gush over them gush
over them don't try to act like you're
not or or just like say your piece and
say how much you respect them and love
them and and move on from there you know
you